[Music]
one very interesting set of points
within philip k dick's address the
android and the human have to do with
the status and the potential
of kids of youth of
young people and he's writing this in
the early 70s so i'm an example
at this point in time in my early 50s of
the you know very edge of the kids that
he's talking about he's also talking
about those who would be 10 years 15
years older than me the very end of the
baby boomers the beginning of what we
now call generation x and dick
talks about them as being a reason for
a sort of optimism
within a society in which we are
becoming more and more closely enmeshed
with our machines and which
is is eroding the distinction between
android on one side and human being on
the other
not just as a abstract sort of
individual thing but also
promoted within our society in a variety
of ways he discusses psychotropic drugs
that are used to control behavior he
talks about the state he talks about
other entities he talks about the
technology that is enabling this and he
sees the kids
as a
way
or actually a not even a movement but a
tendency for resisting what he calls the
wholesale production
of the
android life form and so we should
remind ourselves of something that's
encapsulated here
in one statement becoming what i call
for lack of a better term in android
means as i said to allow oneself to
become a means to be pounded down
manipulated made into a means without
one's knowledge or consent the results
are the same but you cannot turn a human
into an android if that human is going
to break laws
every chance he gets androidization
requires obedience
most of all predictability it is
precisely when a given person's response
to any given situation can be predicted
with scientific accuracy
that the gates are open he says for the
wholesale production of the android life
form what good is a flashlight if the
bulb lights up only now and then when
you push the button any machine must
always work to be reliable the android
like any other machine must perform on
cue right so
youth
is able to
resist this in some way
and to to go to a passage that we're
going to look at a little bit more later
on
he talks about walt whitman's marching
to the sound of other drummers and he
says it could be rephrased this way
falling not in response to unexamined
unchallenged alleged verities but in
response to a new
and inner and genuinely authentic
human desire and he says youth
of course has always tended towards this
in fact this is really a definition of
youth so he's not just talking about the
kids of his time he's talking about
adolescence and even young you know
adults
as this
body that because it's to some degree
you could say
alienated or repressed or has other
reasons why it doesn't buy into the
society resists
what he's calling
androidization and this is a good place
to get to look at something that he's
also calling
a new individuality we could talk about
kids these days and kids these days is a
great expression because it's perennial
right
the kids these days are the ones who i'm
teaching in my college classes and 20
years from now they'll be talking about
kids these days themselves and there'll
be a new breed over and over again so
we're looking at the kids of the 70s
that dick says that he's spent a lot of
time with and they are inspiring him
with optimism we're also talking about
kids in the past and we're talking about
kids in the future and all of us
most likely
have
been
those kinds of kids
to some degree at one point or another
so he says as the children of our world
fight to develop their new individuality
their almost surely disrespect for the
verities the truths that we worship they
become for us and by us i mean the
establishment a source of trouble they
get in the way they don't do what it is
that is expected demanded required
of them and notice what he says here
this is very very interesting
it's not the politically active
youth that he particularly
has in mind it's not organized
resistance revaluation they're too easy
to co-opt in many ways he says i don't
mean those politically active youth
those who organize into distinct
societies
with banners and slogans why not
to me
that is a reduction into the past
however
revolutionary those slogans
might be and he says i'm referring
instead to those intrinsic entities
what is that the kids each of whom is on
his own doing what we call
his thing and so he gives an example
here that is a good distinction that
might help flesh this out
he may for example not break the law by
seating himself on the tracks before
troop trains remember this is at the
height of the sort of
failing of the vietnam war when draft is
still going on so laying down on the
tracks to interrupt the deployment of
troops is a political act right so he
says it wouldn't consist of that
necessarily his flouting of the law may
consist in something different for
example
taking his car to a drive-in movie with
four kids hidden in the trunk to avoid
having to pay
these two actions have something in
common as he says a law
is being
flouted right the there's a refusal to
go along with the order with the
structure
of things that has been determined
politically the first transgression has
political
theoretical
overtones the second
a mere lack of agreement that one must
always do what one is ordered to do
especially when the order comes from a
posted
printed sign and he says in both cases
there is disobedience
we might applaud the first as meaningful
the political disobedience
the second he says
is merely irresponsible
meaningful political committed coherent
irresponsible with everything else that
that implies so this is a very very
interesting
distinction
that he's making there and a very
interesting valuation dick is not saying
well don't do any political acts or
you know get involved in
decision making or anything like that
but he's saying that there's a
a positive value in certain
circumstances to disobedience
of this sort and he says it's in the
second i see a happier future
there have always been in history
movements of people in organized
opposition to the governing power this
is merely one group using force against
the other the outs against the inns it's
failed to produce a utopia so far and i
think it always will
is the disobedience of youth going to
produce a utopia no more likely
something that's a dystopia
but it's a dystopia
that takes place within
a different kind of larger dystopia and
then produces you could say utopian
enclaves or moments
within it and so
um coming back to this this uh theme
right um he talks about the society
that we're living in one that can be
characterized as a mass
communication of growing totalitarianism
a technological society
and he notes
that this has in some respects failed
and has failed in part
due to the kids it's failed in part due
to other things as well you know we can
think about the corruption of adults not
doing what they're supposed to be doing
and they're acting sort of like kids on
large and making sure that things don't
actually work the way that they're
supposed to so for example if some
company
managed to put out something that would
reduce us all the androids odds are dick
thinks that somebody would have cheated
somebody would have stolen somebody
would have embezzled somebody would have
done less than the work required along
the line and it wouldn't really work
effectively
so he says a couple things here he says
there's been too much persuasion the
television set the newspapers all the
so-called mass media
have overdone it
words have ceased to mean much to these
kids they've had to listen to too many
they cannot be taught because there's
been too great in eagerness too
conspicuous emotive to make them learn
the anti-utopia science fiction writers
of 15 years ago and i was one of them he
said foresaw the mass communications
propaganda machinery grinding everyone
down into mediocrity and uniformity but
it's not coming that way why not so he's
got a great example here while the car
radio dins out the official view on the
war in vietnam the young boy is
disconnecting the speaker so he can
replace it with a tweeter and a woofer
in the middle of the government's
harangue the speaker is unattached as he
expertly hooks up better audio
components in his car the boy fails even
to notice the voice on the radios trying
to tell him something this skilled
craftsman of the kid listens only to
whether there is distortion interference
or a frequency curve that isn't fully
compensated his head is turned towards
immediate reality the speaker itself not
the flattest vokey
dinning from it right so the mass
communication society is losing its
effectiveness you could say right and we
can think about how does this apply in
our day of social media and uh
interconnectivity through the internet
mobile devices right
then he says something else interesting
about totalitarianism
the totalitarian society envisioned by
george orwell in 1984 should have
arrived by now the electronic gadgets
are here the government is here ready to
do it or well anticipated so the power
exists the motive and the electronic
hardware but these mean nothing because
progressively more
more and more so
no one is listening the new youth that i
see is too stupid to read too restless
and too bored to watch too preoccupied
to remember the collective voice of the
authorities is wasted on him he rebels
but
what is the motive for the
rebellion here in this technological
totalitarian mass communication society
it's not well it is for some you know
political coherent
ideological right and they would like to
replace the powers that be with
themselves as powers dick thinks
deep in their heart and maybe they don't
say that on paper
but
he says
the rebellion is not out of a theoretic
theoretical ideological consideration
for most of the youth
only out of what might be called
pure selfishness
self-centeredness
looking at one's own
thing
plus a careless lack of regard for the
dread consequences
authorities promise him if he fails to
obey he cannot be bribed because what he
wants he can build steel or in some
curious intricate way
acquire for himself he cannot be
intimidated because on the streets and
in his home he's seen and participated
in so much violence that fails to cow
him he merely gets out of its way when
it threatens or if he can't escape he
fights back and so here's another prime
example when the lock police van comes
to carry him off to the concentration
camp you know something that's that's
characteristic of totalitarian society
the guards will discover that while
loading the van they failed to note
another equally hopeless juvenile has
slashed the tires the van is out of
commission and while the tires are being
replaced the other youth siphons out all
the gas from the gas tank for his
souped-up chevrolet impala and is sped
off long ago
it says the absolutely horrible
technological society that was our dream
our vision of the future we could
foresee nothing equipped with enough
power guile or whatever to impede the
coming of that dreadful nightmare
society
and here's where it gets very funny
it never occurred to us
that the delinquent kids might abort it
out of the sheer perverse malice of
their little individual souls
god bless them and he gives an example
here of the phone freaks these were
people who figured out back when there
used to be pay phones they figured out
how to hack the system and make as many
free
phone calls back then you had to pay for
long distance calls and you had to pay
to use the pay phones
as many uh free calls as they would like
to make they found a way to break things
they found a way to
steal and so
dick ends up saying
that what he foresees ahead
he says speaking in science fiction
terms i now foresee
an anarchic totalitarian state ahead now
that seems like a contradiction in terms
doesn't it what we call an oxymoron an
anarchic no rule
uh perhaps against any authority
totalitarian
where it's not just that there is a
hierarchy in order but it's you know
it's totalizing it's supposed to extend
all society how can the two of these
coexist together well there's going to
be government there's going to be all
sorts of things like government like
local governments and institutions and
corporations and pick whatever you like
political organizations
and on the other hand there will be the
anarchic
desires
actions
impediments
wrench in the the gears things that
youth are putting forward and perhaps
some adults who remain
like that and so he talks about
where we get some really
interesting positive
content he says that
if we're in the process of becoming a
totalitarian society in which the state
apparatus is all powerful
you know arguably
the case for many people in our society
right now
here's what dick says the ethics most
important for the survival of the true
free human individual
so
maintaining some sort of very important
value
would be what
cheat lie evade fake it be elsewhere
forge documents build improved
electronic gadgets in your garage
that'll outwit the gadgets used by the
authorities that's the anarchic part
right if the television screen is going
to watch you rewire it late at night
when you're permitted to turn it off
rewire it in such a way the police
flunky monitoring your transmission uh
it mirrors his living room back at his
house when you sign a confession under
duress forge the name of one of the
political spies who's infiltrated your
model airplay playing club pay your
fines and counterfeit money or rubber
checks or stolen credit cards give a
false address arrive at the courthouse
in a stolen car tell the judge if he
sentences you will substitute aspirin
tablets for his daughter's birth control
pills or put his honor on a mailing list
for pornographic magazines he's talking
about all these different
modes of rebellion
and then he says you know
results should be interesting shouldn't
they um
so he says
you know this is this is a a
model for how we ought to behave and one
of the key aspects of this we just
talked about you know lie cheat steal
evade
is unreliability if you want to avoid
the
androidization
of
things of people if you want to
[Music]
not reduce human beings to that you have
to become
unreliable and here we go back to
this
original issue that he was talking about
as
central to youth right if you become
unreliable
then
you cannot become the
uh
the android because the android is
supposed to be there to do the same
thing over and over again and so this is
why he says
this is what i wish to hear to say to
you here today i wish to disclose my
hope my faith in the kids who are
emerging now their world their values
and simultaneously their imperviousness
to the false values the false idols the
false hates of previous
generations right he talks about a
tremendous spirit of optimism that i
feel so urgently and strongly that our
collective tomorrow exists in embryonic
form in the heads or rather in the
hearts of those kids who right now at
their young ages are politically and
sociologically
powerless
he goes on and you know he says that we
we need to actually
understand how they are keeping human
nature
alive in some way
and this is where we should
think about something so he is as i
pointed out in the beginning writing in
the early 70s he talks about himself
as um you know living among these kids
in in some manner um
they are a you know source of trouble
uh they're doing their thing right
they're
irresponsible any and he says that
we can put whatever label we want on
this it could be
laziness short attention span perversity
criminal tendencies it could also be as
he talks about at the very end
in
the thing a sort of merryness
and here we go a spirit of merry
defiance of spirited though not
spiritual bravery and uniqueness talking
about the girl who steals all of the
coca-cola right
um
those kids have grown up
i'm
one of i'm i'm one of the youngest of
the kids that he's talking about you
could say i was you know two or three
when he he gave this address
how should we read this now how should
we interpret this now how should we
understand this have we
accelerated have we intensified
this mass communication growing
totalitarian technological society
who are the the kids who are reacting
against it should should they
be more anarchic
rather than political these are all a
set of
open questions that we as we
read and reinterpret this wonderful
address by dick have to think through
in our own time
you